now qatar's prime minister has pledged a
hundred million dollars in humanitarian
Aid to Ukraine Sheikh Mohammed bin Abdul
Rahman althani made that announcement on
a visit to Kiev
well
in continuation of our humanitarian
efforts his Royal Highness has pledged
100 million dollars in order to
alleviate the dire humanitarian
conditions in Ukraine
it will be channeled to the health and
education infrastructure water resources
and demining efforts
let's speak to Steph bass and she joins
us now from the Ukrainian Capital step
tell us a little more about the outcome
of this meeting here
well this was the very first time a
prime minister from Qatar has visited
Ukraine since the two countries have
established diplomatic ties around 30
years ago and of course the Ukrainian
prime minister smihal said the visit
comes at a very difficult time one of
the main topics was the resumption
possible resumption of the grain deal
that collapsed around 10 days ago and
the Ukrainian prime minister said that
Russia by withdrawing from that grain
deal has jeopardized the lives of
millions of people in Africa and Asia
but also of course in the Middle East
there's a lot of concern so Qatar has
now pledged a 20 million dollars to help
resume this grain deal especially also
for nations in Africa and also on the
table was this zelenski 10 point peace
formula which was launched last year
both leaders have discussed how to
implement more practically this peace
formula they looked at Food security the
grain deal for example but also and G
security but also looking at Education
Health Care so there was a lot to talk
about a very far-reaching meeting step
by I know Ukrainian officials have
welcomed qatar's Readiness to mediate in
the efforts to repatriate those
thousands of Ukrainian children that
were taken to Russia since the beginning
of the invasion what more do we know
about that
yes indeed when Russia occupied these
territories in Ukraine it's estimated
that 6 000 children have been taken away
to Russia and Russia says it wanted to
protect this orphans but the Ukraine
says these children are illegally
abducted so in March the ICC the
international criminal court has
actually called this a war crime and has
issued an arrest warrant against
President Putin for this deportation and
now Qatar has offered to mediate with
Russia about the return of these
children how exactly that will happen we
have no details about this plan but this
is of course Very welcomed by The
ukrainians Who see this as a very
serious crime and offense and they
really want these children to be
returned as soon as possible
steadfast in there with the latest for
us from Kiev and that meeting thank you
step